it's on
all right let's start officially
welcome to the ddps seminar everyone
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over some rules and logistics
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
admit and ask otherwise please use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in q a session at the
end
second today's gdpr seminar is open to
external audiences
therefore no classified discussion is
allowed so please watch out
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our youtube channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
it is an honor to host pat
now who is a director of the institute
for the study of learning and expertise
and as a research scientist at
stanford's center for design research he
has contributed to ai and cognitive
science for more than 40 years
having published over 300 papers and
five books on these topics
dr lenny developed some of the first
computational approaches to scientific
knowledge discovery and he was an only
champion of experimental studies of
machine learning and its application to
real world problems
he is
the founding editor of two journals
machine learning in 1986 and advances in
cognitive systems in 2012
and he is a fellow of both
triple
triple ai and the cognitive science
society dr lange
current research focuses on
architectures for embodied agents
abductive methods for plan understanding
and learning procedures from written
instructions
today pat will give a talk
with the title of computational
scientific discovery
heuristic search for communicable
laws and models
please enjoy his wonderful talk and now
without further ado let me pass the
button to
pat by asking one random question as
usual today's random question is what is
your favorite things to do other than
research
and other than arguing with other
researchers
i agreed science fiction probably
oh okay so that is still related to the
science
okay um yes it's often a lot i think a
lot of us have been motivated by by
ideas we encountered in science fiction
in the earth that's true yeah
i like history too
that's wonderful that's wonderful um
surprisingly i i often um get inspired
by uh some songs
also
yeah well you'll have to sink for this
later
all right uh
thank you pat it's all yours stay tuned
very good
thank you everyone for coming
um
and uh first thanks to uh to my many
collaborators this is just a small set
um i know lucha todorovsky is is uh is
signed in so if you have any questions
for him
and you run out for me you can ask him
later
and my funders many funders over the
years
um
this talk is broken into two major parts
the first is largely historical
and the second is about more recent
research that i've done
so i'm going to give a lot of background
and one of the reasons i'm doing that is
because uh this topic has has suddenly
become over the past five six years
become uh
getting a lot of attention but many of
the people who are working in the area
don't seem to be aware of the 40 plus
years of research on it so so some of it
is i think a very important review so i
think we would all agree that science is
a unique activity it's uh
there are other
areas of
of human life where we
try and understand things or
or
[Music]
make progress but science is
distinguished by a reliance on formal
laws
models and theories of of observations
and i'm thinking about things like
kepler's laws of planetary motion
newton's theory of gravitation
the krebs citric acid cycle
um dalton's atomic theory and
we typically refer to the activity of
finding
these kinds of accounts as scientific
discovery there are other aspects of
discovery like finding new particles or
planets but but
often when we talk about discovery we're
talking about finding laws or models or
theories
now
i want you to
imagine yourself back in
1971 72
when i was an undergraduate in college
and this is what people thought about
scientific discovery back then it was
mostly what what karl popper wrote in
he said that
discovery is very interesting maybe
psychologists could could look at it but
but it's not really
subject to logical analysis
he said the initial act
of conceiving or inventing a theory
seems to me neither to call for logical
analysis nor to be susceptible of it
it may be expressed by saying saying
that every discovery contains an
irrational element or a creative
intuition
now popper set the stage for this but
there were many other philosophers who
believe that carl hempel uh said it
repeatedly and this is what i was
exposed to as an undergraduate in my
philosophy of science course and i went
that can't be right because i was taking
courses in cognitive psychology in
computer science since i was starting to
read uh some of the early ai work and
and i i said no we we can do this we can
understand what's going on discovery um
and it was advances in these two fields
cognitive psychology and ai uh
which really took off together in the
1950s that that opened the door to
attract attacking this
and herb simon
who was my advisor at carnegie mellon
uh he
was the one who championed this cause in
the mid 60s he said
well scientific discovery isn't really
that mysterious it's really a form of
problem solving
which he equated with
search through a space of problem states
that are generated by applying mental
operators
and they're guided by heuristics to make
that search tractable
much like
um exploring a maze where you're trying
to find your way to the end and there
are certain rules heuristics like keep
your hand on one side and so on that
will help you get to the end
now heuristic search even then had been
and implicated in many cases of human
cognition from proving theorems to
playing chess to to lots of other areas
um and and simon said
well it's not limited to that we can
apply the same ideas to explain what's
going on in scientific discovery not
only to model how humans discover new
scientific knowledge but how to automate
that process in running computer
programs
so here's the generic task okay
you're given a set of scientific data or
phenomena it doesn't have to be numbers
that you want to to to model to account
for
you're also given
in some sense a space of candidate laws
or hypotheses or models and that those
are stated in some established
scientific formalism and we're going to
come back to this later because it's a
very important point that distinguishes
work in this area from pretty much
everything else in machine learning
uh and you're also given knowledge uh
about the scientific domain and maybe
heuristics to help you guide search
and the output the result which you want
to find are laws or models that describe
or explain the observations and of
course you want them to generalize to
new cases but first you gotta gotta get
the handle the the observations you got
and i'll come
discuss later the distinction between
description and explanation which is a
standard
uh distinction in the philosophy of
science
anyway simon said hey we can develop ai
systems that care carry out heuristic
search through a space of alternative
laws or models or theories and that's
how we're going to account for discovery
well you all know this story right uh
this is this is uh albert einstein and
his discovery of e equals m c squared um
where you can see that he was doing
systematics it's a careful search
through the space of hypotheses until he
finally got a clue as to as to what the
solution was um this is not actually how
simon now how al einstein found it and
but this is an example of a very simple
kind of search called generate and test
i don't think that's what human
scientists use very much but it it does
uh if you have trouble remembering the
idea of discovery a search you can think
back to this uh to this gary larson
cartoon
so
so i went to carnegie mellon in 1975
specifically to work with herb simon on
scientific discovery and
by the end of the decade i had developed
a system
that adopted incorporated his ideas
it carried out search through a space of
theoretical terms
it used mental operators that combined
old terms into newer higher level ones
it guided its search by heuristics that
noted regularities in the data
and it applied those recursively to
formulate higher level explanations
i call the system bacon
because it uh it was named after francis
bacon because it adopted a data driven
approach to discovery and it and i
showed that it could rediscover laws
from the history of physics and
chemistry
here's a very simple example and this is
going to look trivial to you i'll tell
you at the time people were telling me
you couldn't do this okay so
so
and this is again in the late 70s uh
here are some data
from borreli on on the the
distance of jupiter's moons
from the primary and their periods
and um
and
you might notice that if you uh if you
if the the distance and the period are
increasing with each other that might
suggest that if you should look at their
ratio because it might be that they
increase together because the ratio is a
constant in fact it's not
but now if you look at
uh d over p
and d you find that uh that there they
when goes up as it goes down so that
suggests you might look at their product
that's also not a constant but if you
look at the product of these last two
d cubed over p squared that is more or
less a constant and bacon would say ah i
found a law here
it wouldn't stop there uh in cases where
it had experimental control uh in a
simulated environment not a real
lab
it could it could vary one variable at a
time and it could build higher and
higher level laws for example for the
ideal gas law it might hold
the
number of moles and the temperature
constant and and vary
the pressure and see it would find the
volume change and that would lead to a
law p v is the constant it would get
different constants for different
numbers of moles
uh and it would then say well let me
compare relate the number of moles to
this constant it's not a constant
anymore it's varying
and it would find this c over n as a
constant
and then it would vary temperature and
it would find this law which
is equivalent to the ideal gas law
so
using techniques like that bacon was
able to reconstruct from small amounts
of data uh
a bunch of
of numeric laws from the history of
physics and chemistry
mostly physics
the ideal gas law kepler's law third law
coulomb's law ohm's law the law of
reflection uh archimedes law
uh
where he had the eureka moment
conservation momentum and black's law
specific heat you'll see that these are
really not very simple forms right so
it's not you can't do this with say
linear regression although i assure you
people at the time said why are you
doing this this is just regression back
then ai was all about symbol processing
and people a lot of people had trouble
understanding why i was even interested
in in handling numeric data because that
wasn't an ai kind of thing but uh but in
fact i said yes it is and and if you
think about it these
the interesting thing here is not the
parameters the interesting is the
qualitative structure of these laws um
that's what the system was searching so
although it was in some sense doing um
doing regression i think it was much
more interesting than classic
statistical approaches
now
i did this work i continued to work on
it for
on on bacon or various extensions of it
for for some years but but other people
picked up uh the torch too and and and
ran with it and here's a list of systems
that were developed over the the
following uh
20 years that were i would all say
directly inspired by bacon
and i won't go through them all
or say which ones are the most
interesting
i will mention much in one one here rf5
which was kazumi saito's
thesis work
in japan
and as far as i know that was the first
time someone used neural network
technology to search through a space of
of uh of numeric laws uh again inspired
by the vacant work um
so if you're doing deep learning for uh
for
equation discovery you should be citing
his early work uh but these last ones
i'm not gonna i'll talk more about later
because they
but they move beyond
simple equation discovery to what i
would call a kind of model discovery in
particular for differential equations
and uh we'll return to that later
now these all these these had very
different methods okay the thing they
had in common is they searched a space
of explicit mathematicals
to match the data
difference bacon used almost trivial
search techniques okay its main
contribution was to show that you could
do this at all which again was very
controversial at the time
but then people would do use more
sophisticated techniques
in a number of us
by by 1990 we're using multivariate
regression as a subroutine sometimes
i think that some of the legrams work by
toroski and todorowski actually used
genetic programming to search the space
of hypotheses so if you are using that
kind of technique make sure you cite
their work
now the early stages of any science
focus on descriptive laws
like the ones i just showed you uh
sometimes they're qualitative often
they're quantitative um but they're they
really their purpose is to summarize the
data they don't really go go beyond the
data or below the data but
more mature sciences the all of these
were taken from the early stages of
physics or chemistry but mature sciences
instead
emphasized creating models that explain
phenomena and when i say explain i mean
that they are in postulating
components and structures that you
cannot observe
they're hypothesizing
processes about how various
entities interact
so they they really move beyond
description to offer a deeper account
linked to theoretical constructs almost
always some it's not often some kind of
background knowledge about the domain
now can we develop com computer systems
that do this that that replicate this
side of scientific discovery well
yes in fact there's been a bunch of work
in that area too not so much me
but actually some of it goes back to a
system called dendrol which predated
my own work in in discovery that was a
system that inferred chemical structure
from
a
chemical formula
a mass spectrogram and generic knowledge
about chemistry this was in organic
chemistry and that led to many
publications in the chemistry literature
of me chem
which did a similar kind of thing but
for reaction pathways
again using in
in chemistry
dendral was organic chemistry mechan was
physical chemistry um
uh my more recent work by a by ross king
and his colleagues on a system called
adam that combines experimental design
data collection actually uses a robot to
do this uh and causal inference to build
models of yeast metabolism
uh
ailp
by
bohan
at al
one of stephen
students uh uses a something called a
logic programming to infer a food web
for 40 45 invertebrates like spiders
from their relative abundances measured
in the field
and uh more recently a system called ace
developed by
hold on
liz bradley
uh i think kevin anderson and others uh
that uses that uh builds process models
of how a landform was produced
geological landform based on nucleotide
densities of rocks
now these are very different kinds of of
systems from bacon and its successors
because but they are also using now
they're combining not data with
knowledge to guide search to a space in
this case of models it's just that
they're going beyond the data not just
describing it but explaining it in terms
of of unobserved
assumptions
this is an old slide that tries to ship
that shows the diversity of work in this
area
from 1979 to 2000 and there's so i
haven't updated it it's busy enough as
it is you can see that's a bunch of
different
uh pieces of work the the top row is
is the kinds of things i showed you
earlier successors to bacon
these were systems that found
qualitative laws these were systems that
built structural models
and these were systems that built
more process models but all almost all
qualitative
and it didn't stop so i i mentioned that
my work was was trying to reconstruct
examples in the history of of science it
didn't stop there okay of course
um after i after i finished my my phd
people are always saying well this is
all very nice but you knew the answer
will be impressed when you find
something new
and
i've done a little bit of work in that
area but most of the successes have come
from others uh here are some examples
by uh of as i i mentioned reaction
pathways and catalytic chemistry
qualitative factors in mutagenesis
qualitative laws and metallic behavior
uh in mathematics
uh
quantitative conjectures
and graph theory and number theory
uh temporal laws of an ecology and i
mentioned the king's work on on
metabolism and yeast
and there's been others
since then this again is an old slide
this was this was uh
up to date almost over 10 years ago
what was my measure of success here is
that they led to publications in the
refereed literature
of this the relevant scientific field
they were contributing new models new
laws
to the domain science not to computer
science journals not to ai journals
that's how we measure success in terms
of tenure cases right so maybe these
systems well probably they didn't
deserve tenure because they weren't
doing it themselves but they did a
substantial part of the work
and here are some some books that have
come out over the years on this again
these are these are
describing older work uh but
if you particularly if you look at this
most recent one that uh that sacha
jaroszki and luke cho todorowski uh
edited you'll see a great variety of
work it really covers the gamut of work
up through 2007.
i think it's time to do another one
okay
i should mention briefly
the
something called data mining i'm sure
you've all heard of it um
uh in fact when it when the first
conference was launched on this it was
called data mining and knowledge
discovery uh so you sort of think that
it might be related to what i've been
talking about in fact it's uh related
but not as much as you might hope
for as much as i would hope um
the data mining movement first
conference was uh in 1995
uh you know 15 years after after
i published the earliest work on bacon
data mining emphasized large amounts of
data
back then large was maybe a million but
it was still large at the time they did
use computer
techniques to find regularities in the
data
they did adopt the notion of heuristic
search through a space of hypotheses
initially they focused on commercial
applications
and commercial data sets if you went to
the conference pretty much every you
know
eighty percent of the people were
wearing wearing suits um
and
so there's a lot of business interest
and there still is
the big difference is that
that most of the work here and use
notations that were invented by computer
scientists back then it was decision
trees a little later and and and uh
logical rules later it was it was
phase nets
later it was support vector machines and
now i'm sure that there's a lot of work
on on deep learning there
the
it did not use
established scientific formalisms okay
which is what
computational scientific discovery is
all about i would say that's its
defining characteristic because the
output of the system is
a law or model in some some formalism
that scientists themselves know and love
different different fields but
it has to make contact with the
literature that's why i sometimes talk
about it as communicable model laws and
models because these are the notations
that scientists use to communicate their
results
um
sorry but decision trees phase nets
deep neural networks are not it
you may be able to translate them back
into communicable
uh formalisms and some people do that
but that's a key step if you're not
doing that i wouldn't count it there has
been work on scientific data mining some
very impressive work but the output i
would say does not count as scientific
knowledge if it unless it takes this
communicable form
right
okay
so are there any questions
clarifications that came up in the
meantime
uh no clarification question but uh
there's one question from zachary um
well it was a comment um he said that it
seems like an e only important step in
the discovery process
is the determination of what phenomenon
needs to be explained by the same theory
of course so that remind that that just
brings back so many memories okay
because i'll tell you when we when we
when we first published this work we
started in the late 70s and early 80s
and especially after we published our
1987 book on scientific discovery
there were lots of naysayers who would
say oh well what you've done is very
nice but isn't the real problem of
discovery x or y or z
whatevs always something we had not done
it was it was well you have to pick what
variables you're going to relate or you
have to uh you have to find what problem
you're you're going to work on and we
said well of course we didn't say that
we had a complete theory science is
never ending right so we claimed that we
had made progress and we had elucidated
a important aspects of the discovery
process not that we had automated the
whole thing any more than machine i mean
you could say the same thing about all
machine learning work how do you decide
what what problem to look at uh so sure
i think there's something about the word
discovery that sets people off right uh
you see similar kind of results these
days when you say when you use the word
causal some people just think that
somehow our reserve term and and i
personally i think they're they're
really just carbon chauvinist they want
to reserve those terms for people and
they don't want to let silicon
entities be they have
play in that arena
there has been work on problem finding
uh in fact
deepak call carney who was another of
herb simon students did a very
interesting thesis um where he did a
historical replication of krebs
discovery of the urea cycle and and he
he looked at the literature on what
krebs did krebs is always changing what
problems he's working on
based on surprising results and and and
kolkarni's
keikai system uh actually did an in
i thought a reasonable job of of
mimicking that kind of of uh a
problem-finding behavior uh but again it
is understudied plenty of look if you're
looking if i don't know how senior the
person is but if he's a student this is
a great thesis topic if he's an advisor
it's a great topic for his students so
go for it and i'll i want to see the
results
okay let me shift to more recent work
that is building on the stuff that's
gone before so
as we've seen
most of the research on computational
scientific discovery as i've defined it
has focused either on
inducing numeric laws that describe
quantitative observations what is often
called equation discovery um
and i don't make a side note here uh
you'll come across the term symbolic
regression
i believe that john cosa introduced that
around 2001
when he did some work on genetic
programming uh uh for for
finding these kinds of
of laws and models um i think that's a
terrible term because
regression has always had a symbolic
aspect i mean if you
if you do uh
the the the
resulting if you know in advance
the exact form of the equation sure but
if you're doing say multivariate
regression where you do uh where you do
variable selection with say backward
elimination or forward selection then
you're searching a space of model
structures
it's a very constrained space but i mean
there's a strong symbolic element there
there always has been so
so i symbolic regression
contains no content as a term equation
discovery does um and so i'm going to
continue to talk about equation
discovery uh and model discovery and i
hope you will too
um
so uh so again the most of the work in
this area has been on focusing on
discovering equations that encode
numeric laws or
inferring structural accounts that
explain qualitative phenomena
that's arguably more abductive and less
inductive
there's the the data tend to be very
sparse one could question whether they
are data in a classic sense they tend to
be more more qualitative phenomena
and we shouldn't go into the details
there but the point is that that's what
most of the work has been
um but if you look at the more advanced
sciences you some often find
people combining aspects of both
activities they end up coming up with
models that
that
posit unobserved structural relations
among entities
and that include
functional forms with numeric parameters
i would call these quantitative
explanatory models and now the question
is can we can we automate their
construction as well
there has been work in this area too and
i'd say there's two broad classes uh the
first uh
i call abstract causal models uh this is
closely related to what's called
structural equation models that work in
that area was championed by clark
leemore peter spirtis and their
colleagues
but not quite as far back as uh as the
work on bacon but pretty far back late
87 was their first book um
and more recently uh there's been
no no this was in parallel um work on
discovering sets of linked differential
equations and sasho jarossky and lucho
tarowski did some of the earliest work
on this
but there's been other work by stolen
bradley cosa and others
this uh
these
both of these combine numeric equations
into larger qualitative structures but
they i would argue they're still mostly
descriptive
because they aren't postulating
unobserved variables or processes
it's good work
and i'm going to
draw on it but i i think it's not quite
the sense of quantitative explanation
that that that many scientists would
want
let me give you an example so these are
some data from kevin rigo's lab at
stanford he's an oceanographer and these
are every every couple of years he takes
a trip down to the raw sea in antarctica
and they take samples i hope they've
automated it by now i think they used to
have to
drop a bucket in and pull it back out
this is the
number of days of the past
and
of the concentration of phytoplankton
and nitrates nitrogen which is a
nutrient that phytoplankton is known to
rely on and you see that um as the
phytoplankton grows the uh
the
nutrient is is dropping off but there's
this massive die off around
around and around the middle and in the
and then you see the nitrogen going back
up um
at the bottom you see four uh equations
they're different
differential equations in in
my own notation um they talk about
four
that talk about how four derivatives
vary as a function of the the current
values and notice that two of them that
detritus and zooplankton are naturally
not observed uh but they're still part
of the model that
that you have that then there this is a
model that will actually reproduce these
data pretty well so this is again an
example where
this is looks like
finding linked differential equations or
difference equations in this case but
there's more
because if you read papers by people who
do this kind of work by
by ecologists and oceanographers they'll
tell you a story like this they'll say
what's really going on is that as the
phytoplankton uptakes nitrogen absorbs
it it's it it grows that reproduces it
concentration increases and the nitrogen
decreases
that continues until the nitrogen is
more or less exhausted
and that leads to this massive die off
that produces detritus
dead material that gradually
breaks apart remineralizes to replenish
the nitrogen
it may also be true this is this is more
iffy
that zooplankton
grazes on the phytoplankton and that
slows down the
the phytoplankton's increase and it also
produces detritus
that story suggests that you want to
move beyond just describing and
predicting these curves okay um
you want to you want to get at these
under these sound like processes to me
and in fact you can you can identify
parts of the the model that correspond
to them right so so this first part i
phytoplankton uptakes nitrogen that
leads to its concentration increase and
nitrogen decrease
that is associated with these parts of
the
model and this last part
is associated with these parts of the
model right every so so the process is
not a single thing it's a set of things
that are happening together um but it's
not the entire model right so the model
is the collection of these things so we
took that idea
and again this was building on previous
work that
lucho and sasha had done
and and the idea actually came out of
discussions with them
we said we can restructure this into a
set of processes
and here was the notation we came up
with initially um this is what we called
a quantitative process model it's
actually
influenced also by
work by ken forbus
who had developed a qualitative process
language
and this is very much like his
notation except it's got functional
forms and numeric parameters in it and
so this is a
process for phytoplankton loss and you
can see that
it says how much the phytoplankton is
going down and how much trace is going
up this is zooplankton law
zooplankton grazing on phytoplankton
uh nitrogen uptake and remineralization
and so if you turns out you can if you
if you assume that their effects are
additive you can you can end up with
with a model like a differential
equation model like this okay
the the idea here is that each process
is saying that certain terms in the
equation stand or fall together you
could remove this one about zooplankton
right that all the the the highlighted
ones here without touching the others
you'd still have a viable model
it might not fit the data as well but it
would it would be a different model with
different with one less fewer process
okay
so now we come to
the task as we formulated it what we
what we
call inductive process modeling that's
where you have multivariate time series
uh you have some variables you want to
you want to predict maybe not all of
them some of them may be exogenous like
sunlight that you're not trying to
explain
you also have some background knowledge
and i'll come to what that is in a
minute
and then you you run that through your
inductive process modeler and out comes
one or more models that not only fit the
data
but that explained it in terms of these
these unobserved processes right they
are differential equation models but
they are more than that
this is what i mean by this is the kind
of background knowledge that we give as
input these are generic processes they
look just like the processes in the in
the model except that they have type
they have variables um not specific
uh entities
that have types right so one has to be
of type species something else must be
of type nutrient uh they have parameters
and they and the parameters can be in
functional forms
these are equation fragments right this
is not a complete differential equation
this is a piece of a differential
equation but this variable here
this parameter is the same as this one
which is this way of
saying that that some basically it's
it's
adding a constraint about uh about
conservation
so in runs we early runs we did
we had about 25 generic processes like
this
with for example different functional
forms for loss and grazing
those are the building blocks out of
which we're going to build models you
might think that ecologists would have
agreed on what the processes actually
are they don't there's at least 10
different functional forms that are
still actively
used to model
say
grazing processes
so it's uh and and perhaps they're
different ones are applicable in
different different settings we don't
know
um so we built a system called skipping
ipm is inductive process modeling the sc
has
is about
adding structural constraints which i
will not talk about today because i
don't have time
but uh
but uh but here's how the system works
it would use that background knowledge
the generic processes to generate
process instances these were fully
instantiated ones with particular
variables plugged in but without the
parameters right it would then use that
to generate all possible model
structures
and for the kinds of that might be
three or four thousand model structures
that's what we were working with in the
in the problems we were looking at um
again it would reject some if they
violated constraints but it was still a
pretty big search space for each
candidate structure it would then use
gradient to sense search to try and
estimate the parameters to do that it
would actually run the model
with a with some
some sample parameters it would get an
error score and then it would do take a
gradient to send stat now keep going
until it reached a local
optimum and then it would do random
restarts because sometimes it would get
stuck
and
and then it would return
the parameter one or more
uh parameterized models ranked by the
the the error score the rank the for
example the mean squared error and that
led to positive results on on a number
of domains data sets again a lot of this
work was done this was done with will
bridewell uh lucho todorovsky and sasha
travoski and and in some cases others
um
uh the raw sea data that i told you
about um the and we did actually get
journalists good generalization to a
second year not shown here uh this is uh
some laboratory data from uh from
paramecia um
one was eating on the other
uh protozoa um
this is uh data from a
a lake or fjord uh this is predicting
the the levels of of the of the water
this is biochemical kinetics
of what's called a pulse response
experiment where you dump a chemical in
it upsets the steady state and then it
gradually comes back
and others
and so you can see that you can get
not only a variety of handle a variety
of different scientific domains but but
different kinds of behavior this way
which that shouldn't surprise you
because differential equations are a
powerful way of encoding models
we also extended the framework in in
multiple dimensions we built versions
that revised models rather than building
from scratch we introduced hierarchy to
try and constrain the search so you have
processes and sub processes
we
didn't have major overfitting issues but
we did show that an ensemble like
method using something similar to
expectation maximization could improve
results
and also we could use that for uh
sorry
ensembles
are different ensembles
is a kind of model averaging but we
found a way to keep them interpretable
and we also have used a variant on
expectation maximization to handle
missing observations
so again this was arguably a success
but
there were issues
and it's always great when you can write
a critique of your own work before
someone else does um that's what we did
in 2015 adam arvay was a phd student
working with me at auckland
when i was there
and there were a number of problems with
the systems we had built not just
not just the one i told you about but
the whole family
one was that it it had to evaluate
full model structures
so again i told you that it would
generate all possible maybe 4 000
model structures and it would have to
estimate the parameters for each one
well that's not what herb simon was
talking about when he said scientific
discovery is heuristic search that was
exhaustive search and we got to be able
to do better than that it might not be
so bad for simple models but but
but uh but it doesn't scale ultimately
but
perhaps more surprisingly is that we
because we had to do simulation of them
of each model repeatedly in order to
degrade descent to find the model
parameters turned out that took 99.99
of the cpu time
plus we had to do random restarts to
reduce chances of local optimum and so
and despite that sometimes it would
still not find a good fitting model it
wasn't as robust as we wanted now the
reason why we were doing this at the
time and it's it made sense was that and
this is i i don't know for sure about
other recent work in this area but we
were
allowing for
variables that were not mentioned at all
in the data right completely unobserved
uh and so you had to as part of this
process
repeated simulation you would you would
estimate the values of these unobserved
variables
and we were handling non-linear
differential equations so so we were
tackling some hard problems the
the parameter estimation methods of the
time were not sufficient for it it was
just too much and i we went i i asked
four or five experts at stanford
how we should handle this and they
always said oh we do it this way and
that didn't work
luke joe can tell you we tried many many
techniques that were not working for us
finally in 2015 we came up with a new
approach and it as often it involved
rethinking the problem and
and simplifying things at least
temporarily
so
we said
uh
let's assume that processes only have
algebraic eq uh
wait sorry that
let's assume that each process has a
rate
like in chemical reactions right
chemical reactions have a rate at which
they're operating
there's an algebraic equation that
determines that rate and what's more
that's parameter free
there are counter examples okay but
we'll deal with them later
so there's a parameter free algebraic
equation and it's a function of
variables uh that you have known that
that you can measure okay so we're not
we're also backing off of unobserved
variables for now
um and you can observe
one or more derivatives that are that
are proportional
to to that processes rate right so each
process has one or more derivative terms
that are directly proportional to to the
process rate
this has nice mathematical properties
and again it's very similar to uh to
forbice's work on qualitative processes
this is the new notation it's basically
the same as before except each time each
process we have a rate
there's a there's a
one parameter for each differential
equation fragment
but these are always linear
right so they're linear functions of the
rate which is why they're proportional
to the rate
and we can convert this again into
a
set of differential equations this is a
always going to be a linear combination
of
these
of these these terms these are not
if you're not familiar with the the term
linear differential equation these are
linear differential equations even
though they have
could have products or ratios or other
things in them as long as there's no uh
there's no funny things like one over
one plus k where k is a parameter that
screws things up and we'll come back and
we are i i think i know how to deal with
that but i won't report results on it
today
and generic processes
are again very similar uh there you can
have constraints basically this is
saying that a has to be positive this
parameter
that is exponential growth increases
the prey concentration and so on
and we built a system that built that
that incorporated this idea it's
now this one is actually going to carry
out heuristic search
it's going to generate all the process
instances again making them concrete
with particular variables
and then for the from the data
you're going to say if that process was
really active let's calculate what its
rate would be because remember we can do
that because it's just an algebraic
expression of observed variables
and then for each dependent variable
we're going to estimate the the
derivative and then we're going to try
and find the regression for each
derivative term we're going to try and
find a regression equation
in terms of the process rates
this is what it looks like graphically
again this is the task of inductive
process modeling there's two levels of
search
at this level here you at at this you
you have to pick up a derivative you're
going to try and model
and let's suppose we pick this one here
and then you try and find an equation
that predicts that derivative in terms
of
a linear combination of of these process
rates now in in the syst in this system
that we built rpm it does constrained
exhaustive search it would go out to
four or five terms you would try them
all and see which ones work best using
multivariate linear regression to do
that having found that equation it would
then go and pick another variable
and do a search for that the but the
important thing is
that later search for later equations is
constrained by earlier ones
because you knew that once
once a
a process was included in this one it
would have to be if it if it impacted
this very variable you'd have to include
it too so so it was not independent by
any means
and so there's search
at the through the space of models
there's search for equations within
those models
this works well on natural data this is
uh from some some old
1978 data on uh
this uh protozoan uh eco laboratory
ecosystem uh and it's pretty noisy um
but we found we found good r squares for
these
um and this this is a comparison to
to the uh
uh
older skipper skipping system um this is
this is showing you how how variable
the
our exhaustive search system was right
so um it was uh we could we here we vary
the number of of restarts we did this
was this was actually for i think a
three variable
model um so it was really not very very
complicated uh but uh with different
number of restarts it would if you gave
it more restarts it would uh it would
the variations it would be more often it
would find a good fitting model but uh
but sometimes it was a big spread and it
was always taking a lot of cpu time
again because we were doing these framed
estimation rates we were doing
simulation runs again and again and
again some people these days like to
have as much cp use as much ctu time as
possible that's not our style i think
that we could do better
and so
so we then compared that to the new
system
and
it
was
this was it would run different speeds
at different times but it was always
much it was like a million it was almost
a million times less than than the old
system and it was invariably getting
really good fits the data now this was
on small data set but
in the small models but it was but it
clearly would scale better
and here we show that as you increase
the number of
variables this is the synthetic data
with 10 noise uh then as you vary the
number of generic processes that's the
background knowledge and number of
variables um it grows it grows slowly
although it does it looks like it's
faster than linear so so we'll come back
to that
and just to convince you that
this can do non-trivial tasks these are
again synthetic data from a
a 20 species predator prey ecosystem
where one fish is eating the next fish
and so on but we don't tell the system
what order they are and it can
reconstruct
the the
predator prey relationships and the
parameters from data lengthies
i'm going to skip over
some work on on model revision that i
did with adam marve
i did want to show you that here's an
initial model synthetic model here are
the changes you may we made we added a
couple of terms one process and changed
a couple of variables you can see how
different the curves are but the system
is able to recover and adapt the model
only changing things that need to be
changed
and more recently
we've extended
the rpm to
another system that does selective
uh induction of process models we call
it spm
that delays binding the variables um
in the generic processes until it finds
evidence of a relationship it it deals
with it it's able to handle more complex
equations because it actually does
heuristic search through the space of of
uh regression equations using a kind of
backward elimination that by itself
isn't enough turns out that these the
variables here are
highly co-linear i mean massively
co-linear and so
uh if you have more than 10 variables uh
predictive variables uh
classic methods won't work so we we have
to do sampling uh in order to keep the
number of variables small
and it finds multiple equations for each
dependent variable and then it searches
for ways to combine them into consistent
models
i anticipate that i'm running low late
so
so uh
i
just want to show you
that this is a chemical reaction network
that the system was able to reconstruct
from synthetic data
so so the older our rpm the original
system could not have handled this
uh
this is showing how the
backward elimination
uh combined with uh with sampling of the
of the process rates uh leads to much
better scaling as you increase the
number of uh
of
basically the number of terms for each
differential equation so this this is
just fine um up to up to 10 uh cp
cpu-wise right
whereas the old system was clearly
blowing up at that point
and and getting much
much more robust results uh
the older system the early
rpm would uh would sometimes get the hit
dead ends because it was basically doing
greedy search through the space of
models
at the at the model level and it's uh
and the new system is uh is is is doing
much better on on these chemical
synthetic chemical datasets
all right
so i am almost done
so
i said some of this along the way
but let me repeat it
this is building on lots of earlier work
we borrowed ideas on qualitative
processes from ken forbus uh work uh on
inducing differential equation models by
todorowski uh bradley and others
the generic notion of heuristic search
which goes back to simon
i don't mean just for discovery i mean
he and and newell were the first
champions of heuristic search in in the
ai revolution
and multiple linear regression which we
use as a subroutine uh
also notions of delayed commitment in in
uh in search and feature selection
i mean this is bringing together a bunch
of things
uh
i told you that we had made some
simplifying assumptions
uh in order to make this progress and we
did i didn't want to because because
these were
because we thought we had this nice
general framework it was just too
unconstrained so so we need to ex to
extend the system to handle
rate expressions with parameters like
one over one plus k
um
i think we can do that
uh using a form of gradient descent to
estimate them the the parameters it you
can't use straightforward multiple
linear regression
anymore
dealing with unobserved variables i
think we can use an em like method an
integrated optimization method to try
and estimate those as we did in some of
our earlier work
and i've done a little bit of work on
discovering entirely new processes you
don't really want to have to tell the
system in advance what all the generic
processes are
but i think that's a that's the biggest
problem and the most exciting one i'd
love to talk with someone if they know
how to do that
plenty of promising applications
in finding reaction pathways in
biochemistry like metabolic pathways um
uh understanding the ecological dynamics
of of human microflora which are
basically ecosystems of hundreds of
different bacteria
um
of course a topical
topical area would be
better epidemiological models of
contagious diseases clearly we aren't
doing very well at predicting them right
now
but not just discovery okay i'm really
these days fascinated in the flip side
of it which is design if you think about
design it's really you're trying to
discover a model that would if if if if
you had if if it existed
uh you're trying to to design a
situation that would behave in a desired
way rather than the observed way
uh in fact uh
lucho and sasho have actually done some
work in this area um and uh maybe he can
talk about it if he comes to the seminar
um
but i think doing you can do you could
apply that for
for chemical production for finding
metabolic pathways for synthetic biology
i think that i think that those would be
great applications
okay to summarize then inductive process
modeling is this promising approach for
discovering a particular class of
scientific models
it uses the formalism differential
equations that many scientists will find
familiar it uses background knowledge
about the domain
it produces meaningful results with
moderate amounts of data you do not see
millions of training cases right in fact
we were usually working from one
multivariate time series with maybe
hundreds of samples or tens of samples
it generates models that don't just
describe the observations but explain
them in deeper terms and i have we have
have uh methods now that scale well to
many processes and to complex models
now i have to before ending i have to
mention
that there's a whole bunch of work going
on now uh on particularly on inducing
differential equation models
and i list some of it here this isn't
complete
there's two subsets of this there are
some some groups that are using using
various statistical uh techniques to to
find these models
there are others who are using deep
learning in learning in deep neural
networks
which of course you could argue with
statistical but of a different type than
than
usual
and so you see there's a bunch of papers
that have come out on this recently
these are
what do they have in common well they
are searching a space of models stated
in scientific formalisms some of them
for example
this work here by cranmer and battaglia
and others they use graph neural
networks
but then they convert the result into
uh interpretable differential equations
the uh others um
others use uh use different approaches
um and but but they they are they share
this the other thing they have in common
is they don't cite our work
and or luke cho and sasha's work or very
rarely do they uh and it's and i think
that there's one person to blame for
that and that's uh that's uh schmidt
lipson who publishes this very
influential paper in 2009 on finding
differential equation models using
genetic programming and it's good work
except that they
they didn't cite they cited my 1981
paper but they basically miss cited it
they didn't discuss it they didn't
discuss the work by
by luke cho and and sasha on using
genetic programming to find differential
equations so people who read
the schmidt lips and paper think ah what
a great new thing
it's good work but it wasn't new
and
i hope that you will take this as
motivation to go back and read some of
the older literature i do think the
other thing that that
these have in common is i can't
understand them okay these papers are
generally so math heavy and i mean i was
a math major but they are so math heavy
that i have trouble parsing them um and
so i may ask if anyone's interested in
giving me a tutorial on what's really
going on here i would love to learn
because it's clearly important work but
it but the the style of papers if you
read papers by me or the slovenian group
they will have a very different feel
i actually believe you'll understand how
their systems work and to reconstruct
them and these i think it's more
difficult
last comment
we all hear about big data we've been
hearing i've been hearing about big data
since the late 80s
when big data was much smaller than it
is now
there's lots of companies and
funding agencies who want to fund work
on big data i think that that's an
important issue but there's been lots of
lots of progress on it i don't think
that's the real issue
there are two other issues we have to
make progress on one is scaling to large
and complex scientific models ones with
hundreds or thousands of variables in
them
and scaling to large spaces of models
right where there's
thousands or millions of candidates that
we have to search
work on those various on those areas and
i think if you look at what i talked
about today you'll see that i was
addressing those not so much the big
data thing i don't think there are still
plenty of scientific disciplines where
we don't have big data but we do have
big
complex models and we do have big model
spaces
okay there so
scientific discovery is not mystical
despite what
what uh
uh
popper said it's not irrational
we can even study it and partially
automate it
we can view it in terms of searching a
space of laws or models using operators
for generating structures and parameters
guiding search
not only by the data but also by
knowledge and we can discover those laws
and models
stated in formalisms that are familiar
to scientists
there have been lots of successes here
and i hope that i've excited some people
and you will will join us in in this
effort here are some uh some classic
publications and this is the
slide to honor herb simon and jan zitkov
both of who did some of the earliest
work in this area and who combined ideas
from computer science psychology
philosophy and statistics i think they
were great role models
thank you
thank you so much for the great talk pat
that was wonderful talk i liked it
we have
one more questions from from the chat
room
it was from the andre
filippo
he said
the structure of many physical laws
mentioned in the talk followed from
dimensional analysis
broken hands pie theorem does your
approach account for dimensions
and he has um
well do you want to answer that first
question
hold on i'm still trying to find the uh
there it is
okay right
um
i'm not seeing that
but i'll answer it anyway so the answer
is that
of course these are physical laws and
they're going to going to follow the
rules of of of having that the
dimensions have to balance right um the
there has been some work on using
dimensional analysis
uh to uh to constrain the search
for those of you who don't don't know
this i mean in in aeronautics um
of course it was expensive to build wind
tunnels and to build models of
aerodynamics
and so
so some smart people decades ago
realized that uh that you could you
could use
that you could take knowledge about the
dimensions to do
many different experiments would map
onto one point in a dimensionless space
but that's that's not quite what i don't
think that's what the question was about
it's about can you use knowledge about
dimensions to knock out candidates the
answer is yes uh that one of the early
systems uh developed by mitch kokar um
that i cited earl early on he built a
system for equation discovery that did
that um i actually when i was in grad
school i wrote a paper
where i i did that i and i showed that
you could rediscover newton's law with
one data point
but it i didn't get accepted and people
didn't seem interested at the time so
now fine idea um
to my knowledge there's very little that
actually at least to the work that i
covered uh very little work that that
does that
luke joe may know otherwise
uh or someone else may know there may be
some of the more recent work the
recent work on on deep learning for
equation discovery
or quote symbolic regression is uh
is uh
may do that because there's a lot of
interest in incorporating ideas from
physics i just don't know
okay so he has he has a second question
again from andre
physical discovery explains a set of
phenomena
observed before
and shows a way for further research
within a corresponding field such as
physics chemistry biology etc
how does your approach help with that
second part showing perspectives goals
for further research
well
why don't we turn the question around
and say how would suppose that a human
scientist did what
these systems do because obviously these
are all things that human human
scientists have done in the past
how would their activities their results
help move the science ahead
um it it i mean clearly science is not
a bat it's not it's not like batch
processing
even bacon which was incremental it
would take in a few things at a time
um
was basically you gave it some data and
it gave you some equations right and
that's how these systems generally work
uh that's not true for all of them
um as i mentioned this system called
carney did
on
reproducing krebs discovery of the urea
cycle is very much about how new you you
you design experiments you collect the
data the test hypothesis you generate
hypotheses design experiments uh test
them uh revise your model or if
something
really surprising happens you might
redirect your search and go after some
new problem
you see behind a similar kind of thing
happening uh in the work by ross king
and his colleagues on this closed what
they it's a closed-loop uh process that
discovers yeast metabolism models of
yeast metabolism and and so there are
examples like that but they tend to be
coming up with qualitative explanatory
models i haven't seen anything like that
for either
equation discovery or quantitative
explanatory models it could happen uh if
i was going to do that i would look for
something like that right so there might
be residuals
in that you're not explaining so you
look for some new new factor that could
explain why there's this blip here um
that would be a more incremental process
um
but uh but again there's that that's
rarity in the literature as far as i
know that's fine i think that that i'm
interested in how people do things and
and certainly if you want to build a
system that does support scientific
discovery
over the long haul
you're going to have to have that kind
of closed-loop character to it
okay thank you thank you so much for the
um all the answers pat let me just ask
do you usually get more questions than
this or did i lose everyone because i
went on too long
oh well i mean i yeah well it's it's
it's
it's uh it's obviously over time it's we
are uh 10 minutes um after the scheduled
time but i didn't want to um
you know stop your talk because i i want
to have a
the full
full the i want to have the um
here the you know everything prepared
yeah if anyone wants to stick around
afterwards i'm happy to talk or you can
send me email
um and you can find me on the web
email address langley stanford.edu
and you can find lots of papers on this
kind of stuff
sounds good yeah thank you for coming
thank you thank you so much
that was great pat
thank you
good okay let me
stop the